best news ever the He-man liveaction
Movie remake he won't really be a remake
they're not really remaking the Dolph
one are they but the new liveaction
He-Man movie might not be dead after all
welcome to sidey SciFi TV and Movie
Channel I'm so
[Applause]
[Music]
happy
when I was a kid He-Man was by Miles my
favorite cartoon I had all the action
figures I had mechan neck and man at
arms and I think I might have even
watched
Shea I think I
did I I just loved He-Man I don't know
why I just loved it I have watched Kevin
Smith's new animation of He-Man I didn't
love it I can see what he was trying to
do with it but I didn't love it but then
Netflix started developing a liveaction
movie and I was so happy but then I was
so sad when the news hit that during the
strikes Netflix decided to drop the
project even though they'd spent $30
million on investment on development
really they' done a load of the
work and
now looks like they might actually be
selling the project to
Amazon according to variety and several
other sources they are having
discussions at the moment between
Netflix and Amazon Prime about the
project moving across to Amazon now
currently Netflix own the movie right so
it would be a discussion about selling
those movie rights across to Amazon the
project in theory will just move
straight across from Netflix to Amazon
the director will stay on the script
will need to be polished up whatever and
all of that money that's been spent on a
lot of the development work will not get
wasted Netflix will be looking for some
compensation to cover some of that cost
but generally speaking it will just be a
straight move across it will not be
having to start again sort of
thing the big reason why this is
happening is because of Claudia
Valentini who is the woman that at the
start of this year got hired by Amazon
to be the new head of production and
feature films basically for MGM and
Amazon if you're a regular Sid trer
you'll have heard that name a few times
before it's one of the reasons why we're
still waiting on Stargate is because
they needed to wait until they hired
this woman and um the fell that took
over management of feature films like
actual like the Hands-On production
management side but
anyway she used to work for Warner
Brothers and she was instrumental in the
deal that got Warner Brothers the Barbie
movie with Mattel so she has really good
links with Mattel and that is why it's
rumored that she's so Keen to get the
He-man franchise but also why it's
possible because she has the connections
she knows the people involved etc etc
so we might still be getting a
liveaction He-Man
movie but
the production costs are estimated to be
$200 million and the reason why Netflix
decided to scrap the idea was because
they just could not figure out how to
bring those costs
down so they decided to cut their losses
at 30 million uh rather than spending
another
170 Amazon are very keen not to spend
$200 million on this movie because the
chances are it'll go straight to Prime
you can't spend $200 million on a movie
that go straight to streaming you just
can't so there are still some hurdles
that need to be jumped over but as I say
according to variety and several other
sources these conversations are
happening it is something I'd heard a
couple of rumors about but no more than
that and it does seem that this is let's
say
possible so we could see He-Man
mechcanic
Mana AR
and and so battling Skeletor one more
time in a liveaction movie that might
actually be a He-Man movie this time
rather than whatever Dolph lram
[Music]
did I have
power it's almost a humanman movie but
hey let's fingers crossed that this deal
can happen and let's fingers crossed
that it can do a smooth transition
across to Amazon and they're not going
to have to find a new director and blah
blah blah because that will slow
everything down by
miles but in the mean time I've got to
get to work I just really wanted to tell
you guys because I am genuinely buzzing
about this it's a little bit of my
childhood coming back and I can't wait
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification help us out you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to s.c. which is our dedicated
website where we do articles based on
most of these videos and you can also go
to patreon.com citre where most of our
videos Premiere
first as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next
[Music]
time